how do you think social media has
influenced women's standards and men's
oh a lot I think social media in general
just change relationships because you're
seeing all these Instagram models and
it's not real like nothing's real really
and so that's there like you're at home
with your girl or your man or whatever
you're seeing all these models and that
and they're like they might be liking
your stuff dma new and stuff so it's
just like
or I could get that but then
when you meet him in real life it's not
the same so that's that the standards of
just risen and it's just so sad because
it creates a competition between the
partners and there should be no
competition but it should be like it's
like Valentine's Day people post post
their stuff oh I've got this massive
Teddy I've got all these chocolates like
and sometimes it's fake it's not even
yeah you just put you're just doing it
to prove oh my boyfriend's likes me more
than your boyfriend likes you whatever
it's like a competition it's true if you
really love it it's like an ego thing
yes there we go thanks a lot of times on
Valentine's Day that's when you find out
everyone's got a b as well yeah
this whole time like you had a man the
whole time literally crazy I think the
problem as well is like people think the
the grass is greener in the other side
you know and then you just realized and
they're like [ __ ] it's not and then they
go back and they go back
then to you know to accept them but who
do you think does that more men or women
when it comes to divorce
um women file for divorce 70 of the time
well that's and college educated women
it's 90 oh
second thing is
um 20 of men have access to 80 of women
so the reason that women think all men
are players is because they're all
sleeping with the same ones the majority
one in three men under one in three men
under 30 or six proud to be part of that
twenty percent
so one in three men under 30 are virgins
um and I'm going to give you an example
so so for me right I'm I'm 5 11 and a
half I'm close to six foot right I
prefer guys to my height or taller right
or close to my height but let's say I
wanted six foot or taller I'm six foot
five
um that that's only 15 of guys on top of
that if you have a specific type so you
got a small car agreed to it right so
and and let's say I want a guy that
makes more money than I do and is more
driven than I am that's an even smaller
percentage so again the reason like
women think men are players is because
we're all sleeping with the same ones
yeah
because yeah and then men are dogs so
they'll just sleep with anyone
let me let me just be quiet yeah yeah
so you think so you'll sleep with anyone
like I'm saying guys guys will sleep
with girls and it's not it's not a big
thing but girls they're like so
selective like as we should be like I
should be but the more peaky we are the
more unless we find a good choice
sometimes you know sometimes you are so
picky we just actually like choose the
player the wrong one the wrong one well
and then we we get stuck no you know
it's all it's our fault because we have
we have the beautiful guy in front of us
and he's giving you everything you want
but you're like that's not my time well
it's because a lot of times because we
don't like too good but we don't like
too bad no no it's because a lot of
times attraction cues so the same the
same attraction cues that make the guy
the hero makes him the villain so you
ever wonder why those girls stay with
that guy that's so aggressive and just
hits walls and you're like what is wrong
with this [ __ ] like why are you still
with him it's because like she knows he
can protect her
so like aggression is attractive to us
because the hero has to be aggressive he
can attack her as well what okay no but
that's that's why you see women stay a
lot of times in abusive relationships
yeah like because at like I mean
obviously no girl is attracted to a guy
beating the [ __ ] out of her but that
that trait the that's a masculine trait
yes and like women are attracted to
dominance and you're also attracted to
men that other women want because it's a
form of pre-selection so like back in
the day if you saw a guy that that had a
lot of girls around that that was an
indication that he could take care of
them like social proof is very important
to women in dating like that's why you
see guys with check marks just get like
ugly guys get a little bit of Fame they
get a model
like that
so Go's always just gonna go for trash
men basically
pretty much well I hope not it's like a
Never End inside well it kind of it kind
of depends because a woman a woman go
through phases so like under the age of
like 27 women
um tend to go for like the bad boy the
player but as they see their looks like
starting to run out basically they have
to pick a guy that's a better bet yeah
no because like as women get older like
you've lost like um your options cut in
half by the time you're 30 as a Woman
based on like dating app data I actually
had like a great guy for seven years and
you wanted to marry me and then I moved
to London and then I met this
he's a good guy but he's toxic if that
makes sense he's a player and yeah I
feel like we are quite attractive to
players because I feel there's like some
narcissist uh trades or not even as
women that we need to fix sometimes I do
believe like queer track where we are in
a way yeah and if we attract someone
who's a player it's because you play
yourself as well in a way and you meet
that person in order to
fix some narcissist traits within you
and you guys are gonna meet her like
each other you know I do think like have
you ever heard that recently have you
ever met those people that are like in
toxic relationship after toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
but it's never them they are never the
problem but there just happen to be the
common denominator do you know I think
that comes from wanting to fixing people
and thinking that you can fix their
problems that's the way women kind of
avoid accountability for their part yes
they ignore their own things and then
they well no no I I think women often
times what I what I've seen is like
women will say oh I'm a fixer and like
kind of make it seem like they're the
good one the guy's the bad one they're
just trying to fix him but really like
they have some toxic traits too and they
don't admit to it I think we all do they
don't try to fix no one like fix
yourself it doesn't work it doesn't work
I know as women we are like the nurture
and the the man is the provider and as a
woman like we have the tendency tendency
of like being you know like smothering
not giving the love like fixing helping
nurturing but we have to stop with that
with men we have to stop with our
children
because they get a tantrum and they get
spoiled and they do whatever and they
play you and then you feel like oh my
God I give so much but I think women
think like their car yeah but that's not
oh my gosh but that's not the that's the
exception that is not the norm oh come
on